hello hello there hello so your argument
is that we have to prove that Jesus was
Muslim sure yeah so um well the meaning
of Muslim means the one who submits to
God the one true God just like all the
prophets like Adam Moses Jesus and Jesus
submitted to God so that makes him
Muslim if I submit to God but the god I
believe in is a statute am I a Muslim no
like you have to meet submit to the one
true God like the one the same God Adam
the same God as Moses the same God as
Abraham who is that same God as Jesus
give me a couple of descriptions of him
that like make him like you know that I
could identify him like you can't the
thing is you can't describe he's just
the being like the above us why do you
refer to him as he well that's how we
refer to him as a scriptures it's not
doesn't mean that he a person so in the
scriptures he's described or is he is
that correct not NE not not meaning that
he's a man but that's how the scriptures
describe him right yeah okay okay so he
so if I were to say she then that would
be wrong right well not necessarily but
we just call him he because that's what
it's in the scriptures so it wouldn't be
wrong just be clear it wouldn't be wrong
if I addressed Allah as she he was like
technically the term of respect to God
why doesn't necessarily mean he a man it
was just he as right just like she
wouldn't necessarily mean a woman but
you know I'm showing him respect I can
refer to him as she right but like what
does that have to do with the argument
now though well because I'm trying to
see if we can you know specifically
identify who you're saying God is but we
can't even you know we can't
even or she the same God in the Quran it
says that it's the same God of Adam
Moses Abraham and Jesus yeah but PR to I
know I I know I this is what I'm
challenging this claim so when you say a
Muslim just submits to this God specific
this true God who is that yeah the same
God that Jesus submitted to yeah who is
that the one that created the universe
the one that you know is not like
doesn't associate itself with other gods
you doesn't have Partners okay you know
the one that created everything in Islam
you can't really describe him as like
something but you can't really say he
has hands or feet or anything but the
Quran does the Quran says he has hands
and feet they use that as like a term we
like for us to understand but he doesn't
have hands no the Quran the Quran says
he definitely has hands he says that he
created Adam with both his hands yeah
that's just the way for us to understand
understand what in the Hadith it says
that Allah will show up and he will show
his shin to the Believers and then
they'll bow to him the shin is a leg
bone It also says that you know how you
like will tell the difference between
the the D right the false Messiah and
Allah yeah it says know that your lord
is not oneeyed so the Jal has one eye
and he says your lord is not one eye so
that you don't get confused with him and
your lord so Allah has more than one eye
no he doesn't he doesn't have eyes yes
he does so so then why does Muhammad say
that you'll be able to tell the
difference between the D and Allah
because Allah is not oneeyed well I'm
not really like you know familiar with
that topic but we're just trying to say
that you know the God is like the one
true God he is whatever like it wants to
be but you can't really describe him
from this world he controls everything
he's all knowing allseeing he doesn't
want people to you know worship Dees or
you know associate him with Partners the
same God that Jesus worshiped all right
so let's go with that does make him
Muslim you're giving me you're giving me
something to work with so he has no
Partners he's not like his creation
except that he has hands eyes and the
feet and leg bone but that's another
story you're not familiar with that
topic so I'll let you slide on that but
um and uh does he have children does he
have any sons or daughters well he
created everything so if you want to
refer to him the father of the creation
then you can can you show me that in the
Quran that you can refer to him as your
father we can't really refer to him as
the father okay we well we don't refer
to him as a father but we do believe
that he created everything understand we
do believe with his with his Blessing
that like you know everybody was born so
if you want to use the father in that
sense then you could that's fine so can
you show me in the Quran where that's
allowed where you're allowed to call
Allah your father uh in the sense that
he's your creator well I'm not familiar
if you're allowed to call him your
father or not it actually says to say
that is an atrocious thing Chapter 19
Verse uh uh 89 says they say that all
they say that Allah has taken to him a
son they have uttered an atrocious thing
that the heavens that's crumble what
that's that's directly I'm pretty sure
that verse is directly speaking about
Jesus itself that like the people of
Jesus said that God is his father so if
Jesus said that God is his father then
that would be outside of Islam he
couldn't be a Muslim right that cuz an
atrocious thing to say yeah okay so now
let me let's do this then where do you
get it from that uh you know that Jesus
believed in this God that you find in
the Quran how do how do you how do you
verify that how do you prove that to me
that he submitted and believed in that
God that we see in the Quran well it
says that like Jesus showed in the Bible
that you know that he worshiped God and
he showed the people to worship God and
it also says that in the Quran what
what's a verse that you could think of
give me give me a verse that you uh that
you think of in the Bible where Jesus
worships
God well he teaches you know his
disciples how to worship God so he
teaches his disciples how to worship God
is that right like he teaches them how
to pray and stuff right okay he submits
to God he teaches them how to pray you
know he teaches all the things that you
know Muhammad taught so how did how did
Jesus teach them how to pray he bowed
down to God and the same way Muslims
actually pray the same way Jesus prayed
all right so I'm going to go to the
verse where Jesus bowed down let's see
what he says so it says and going a
little further he fell with his face on
the uh to the ground saying father if it
be possible that this cup pass for me
but not my will that your will be done
it's Matthew 26:39 so when he prayed
prostrating he prayed specifically to
his father yeah like Muslims we
prostrate down with our heads now and we
believe in the one true God but yeah
Jesus Jesus prayed to his father when he
when he prostrated and you said if he
were to do that then he wouldn't be a
Muslim to say well like we believe the
Bible was also corrupted but you said in
the Bible it teaches that Jesus prayed
prostrating and this is so this is what
you reference he refers to him as the
father Yes is because he didn't have a
mother so like he was born through Mary
so then he's not a Muslim for saying
that God is yeah so he's not a Muslim
for saying that God is his father right
no he is a Muslim but earlier you told
me that to say that Jesus is the son of
of God and if Jesus said this then he
would be wrong and not be a Muslim you
said yes you said that yeah that mean
he's not a Muslim so we see here he's
prostrating and calling God his father
yeah which mean which means he's not a
Muslim well like I'm not really familiar
with the you know the Bible like
completely but or that chronic verse you
mentioned chapter 19 chapter 19 yeah
Chapter 19 Verse 88 to 93 it says they
say that Allah has taken unto himself a
son they have uttered an atrocious thing
and the heavens collapse and the the
Earth crumbles and the mountains crumble
uh at that saying that Allah has taken
unto himself a son so we believe like
claim to be a prophet not like the
actual Son of God born through remember
remember I asked you how can you Prov to
me that Jesus believed and submitted to
this God that's described in the Quran
you said well it's even in the Bible you
went to the Bible and said so Jesus
taught how to worship God he taught his
disciples how to pray and stuff and when
he prayed in the B he prostrated so
you're you're you're referring to the
Bible and in all of these places
actually that you're referring to Jesus
is Calling God his father when he prays
when he teaches his disciples about God
and teaches people how to worship like
for example when he's teaching people
how to worship he says um that uh God is
spirit and says that the father is is uh
looking for those to worship Him in
spirit and in truth so he says when he's
teaching people how to worship God he's
saying they have to worship the father
in spirit and in truth so so all of this
stuff goes against what Muhammad taught
right we were taught that Jesus was a
prophet you know and received divine
revelation from his birth right so that
all of the prophets before him
spread I understand I know that I know
what you're taught so what we're doing
is we're putting what you're what you're
taught to the test when we actually look
at what Jesus taught we see that he
actually is teaching things that goes
against Islam right uhuh so therefore he
can't be a Muslim but the thing is like
Islam existed like to be a Muslim it
existed way before the Quran no it
didn't so like yeah like to be a Muslim
like we believe the first Muslim was
Adam so I know you do see again I know
you believe that you get me I know you
you're telling me what you believe I'm
asking you to prove these things and so
already see I I didn't even say let's
even go way back to Adam let's start
with Jesus prove that Jesus was a Muslim
and you can't do it actually we see that
he wasn't he's far from it when we look
at what Jesus taught and how he
practiced his religion it goes directly
against Islam right well like to be a
Muslim like after Muhammad is to believe
in Muhammad but before Muhammad like
before the Quran you know like you you
can say he's not a Muslim because of a
chronic verse the Quran didn't exist
back then yes I can I can't say that
because wait are you saying that Allah
changes does does God change you're
saying that Allah is God so does he
change well in our religion it does yeah
does say that like each book each
Revelation was sent for each time period
and each specific group and we believe
that the Quran was sent for the whole of
humanity and he was the last messenger
well let me show you what let me show
you what the Quran says about about that
then about people back then before the
Quran before the quran's time people
used to say that Jesus was the son of
God let me tell you what the Quran says
about that this is chapter 9:30 it says
the Jews say Ezra is the son of Allah
the Christians say the Messiah is the
son of Allah that is their statement
from their own mouths they imitate the
sayings of those who disbelieved before
them so people back in the day they used
to say this and those were disbelievers
if you said that Jesus was the son of
God you're a disbeliever and then it
continues may Allah destroy them how how
deluded they are it's because they don't
believe him as a prophet he they believe
in the Trinity and the Son of God they
believe him they believe they believe
he's a prophet too but has nothing to do
with him his prophethood here it has to
do with his sunship saying that Jesus is
the son of God makes you a disbeliever
in the past and now you get what I'm
saying he isn't
like I get what you're saying but like
it doesn't like if you believe him that
he is God then yeah you are a
disbeliever
well let's it look what it says to say
that Jesus is the son of God you're a
disbeliever and Allah destroys you so
whoever says Jesus is the son of God
Allah is against them and is out to
destroy them and they are a disbeliever
in the past and even now it's because
Jesus never claimed to be the Son of God
or God but we just read it we just read
that when he prayed he claimed to be the
Son of God that's what you refer to us
as Muslims we believe in all the
revelations like the Bible the Torah but
we believe that you don't see when when
you say that you don't believe that you
don't believe in the Bible when you say
that that it's corrupted but notice this
you went to the Bible to say that Jesus
is a Muslim and he worshiped God yet
when we look at what the Bible says and
how Jesus practiced his religion we see
that by Islamic standards he's a
disbeliever and Allah fights against him
because he says he's the son of God
right well like we don't whatever like
the Quran confirms with the Bible then
that's the that part of the Bible is
true we believe we don't believe
necessarily the whole Bible Well you you
didn't answer me though you didn't
answer me Jesus says that he's a Son of
God in the Bible when he prays so by
Islamic standards Jesus is a disbeliever
right if like Jesus referred to God as
his father father then yeah it doesn't
say father father whoever says look I'll
read it again come on Omar don't be like
the past Muslims that came up here
before you be honest with the text and
be have integrity man please don't be
like them don't revert to that I'm going
read it again be honest with your text
the Christians say the Messiah is the
son of Allah that is their statement
from their mouths they imitate
disbelievers that came before them may
Allah destroy them how they are deluded
so if Jesus is saying which is what we
saw Jesus said that he's the son of God
when he prays father let this cup pass
from me nevertheless let my let not my
will be done let your will be done
praying to his father God is his father
claiming that he's the son of God so by
the Quran standards Jesus when he says
he's the son of God he is a disbeliever
and Allah wants to destroy him right I
guess but that doesn't like I see what
you're saying but we as Muslims don't
believe in like the Bible is today we it
was written by its um brought who
brought up the Bible you or me I did
yeah whatever whatever confirms like in
the Quran like the same in the Quran
then that that part of the Bible will
believe not necessarily the whole thing
but you're the one who said that Jesus
prostrated when he prays in in the Bible
you said that was true yeah Jesus taught
how to worship God the parts he taught
his disciples that part's true so the
part where he prostrates he calls God
his father this is something you said
was true why are you backtracking now
why are you backtracking now I just came
here to prove that Jesus was Muslim do
you see do you see how that's impossible
well you're using the Quran as like the
only way to prove that you are a Muslim
I want to ask you this man um from this
conversation did you see how it was
impossible to show that Jesus was a
muslim with that one point you made sure
but there's probably like you know like
there's probably like a meaning behind
that verse if you can't really just take
it like oh really you think that there's
a you think there's a secret meaning
behind whoever says Jesus is the son of
Allah is a disbeliever and who whoever
says that Allah has a son has uttered an
atrocious thing yeah if you say Allah
has a son you're describing as a human
you can't say that oh but you can refer
to him as a father of all creation show
me in the crown where you can do that
well I don't know exact verse but there
is no verse it doesn't exist but in
Hadith you know if you go to there's no
Hadith there's no Hadith that says Allah
is a father of creation all of it goes
against that what do you mean if you
refer to the father as in someone that
created the whole world
created everything the one true God then
okay then that's Allah yeah the one that
created everything so I believe that
Jesus created everything does that mean
he's Allah well no cuz Jesus you see how
you you see that so you can't you can't
now refer to the generic term Allah or
God um and say that whatever whoever
says whatever they believe in that
created the whole world that's a la
that's a law doesn't matter what
religion you're in or what what your
world viiew is that's talking about
Allah you can't do that because Allah is
something specific he's and and the
father is not one of them you said that
whatever agrees with the Quran and the
Bible that's what you take as true right
that's what you said earlier that's what
Muslims take as true like Islam takes as
true is that the is that what the Quran
tells you to do well that's what you
know the Quran like yeah he says we
confirm all the revelations that became
that you know that came before do you do
you know so okay so the Quran confirms
the previous scripture do you know what
the word confirm means it says that it
means like whatever the God told the
prophets was true but it doesn't it
doesn't say people didn't take it out of
context or change it up oh people yeah
people took stuff out of context they
didn't change the scripture but they
they took the scripture out of context
the quran's clear about that but so but
taking out of context doesn't mean that
the scriptures changed just like the
Quran says they did that with the Quran
too it says that they tore the Quran
into shreds um in context it means that
they took it out of context pick certain
verses that they believed in while
rejecting other other it actually was
memorized when it first came down and
then compil you're not understanding
what I'm saying you're not understand
what I'm saying the Quran itself says
that the people tore it to shreds and in
the context what that means is is that
it's talking about how people was
misinterpreting the Quran and taking
certain parts of it that they agreed
with while refusing the other parts
that's literally what the context of the
verse is talking about okay you
understand what I'm saying yeah okay so
just because you you know misinterpret a
scripture doesn't mean that the actual
scripture is corrupted just means that
your understanding is corrupted make
sense yeah all right so now going back
to now the order of the Quran what what
confirm means and you're right it means
that whatever the prophets said is true
right whatever the prophets of the past
said is true and it says so basically
their scriptures that they have is true
because it's the it's what God revealed
through the prophets yeah like what was
revealed at that time was true okay so
the Quran says that what they have is
true their scriptures are true boom it
never says use the Quran to pick apart
what parts of the scripture are true it
never does that it says that the Quran
has already confirmed that it's true
yeah but it says like that it's also
been changed over time no it doesn't no
it doesn't it
says okay no it doesn't actually it
doesn't say that either in the Hadith
but this is what the Quran says the
Quran says because I'm going show you
it's the other way around you don't use
the Quran to pick what is good and
what's not good in the previous
scriptures you use the previous
scriptures to see if the Quran is true
this is what Allah even told Muhammad to
do if you go to chapter 10:94 this is
what he says in the Quran chapter 10: 94
this is Allah talking to Muhammad he
says this he says so if you are in doubt
about that which we have revealed to you
then ask the those who have been reading
the scripture before you the truth has
certainly come to you from your lord so
never be among the doubters all I'll
I'll say the first part again because
that's the heavy part if you are in
doubt about what we revealed to you then
go ask the people who've been reading
the scripture before you yeah I know
that verse good so if Muhammad is
doubting the Quran the Revelation that
came to him what is he supposed to do to
verify that the Quran is true that his
Revelations are actually on point what's
he supposed to do it's because it's
because Muhammad was um he didn't know
like he was uh you don't you don't have
to explain why you don't have to explain
why just just answer the question
straight away it says go go to go to the
Jews go to the Christians look at their
scriptures and you can tell that this
these all came from God good so do you
see how from the Quran it says that it's
the previous scriptures that show that
the Quran is true or not yeah
you look at like what God Said in the
Quran and then you look at the Bible to
confirm that yes it's it's been said in
the Bible as well exactly now here's my
question so since Muhammad if he's in
doubt about the Quran is supposed to go
check the previous scriptures to make
sure the Quran is in line with them so
that he won't doubt his Quran anymore
what if he checked the previous
scriptures and the Quran actually
contradicted what the previous
scriptures said what would that then say
about the Quran
well God like revealed to Muhammad that
like yes the Bible has been changed no
he okay so so let me get this straight
let's just go with your logic I'm going
show you how stupid that is the the
Bible's been changed so you mean to tell
me that Allah is telling Muhammad that
if he's in doubt about the Quran go and
check the changed corrupted scripture to
make sure your Quran is true well I'm
not familiar with the verse but I'm just
going to say that like I just read it so
if you are in doubt about what we've
revealed to you ask those who've been
reading the scripture before you so is
is Allah telling Muhammad in order so
that he doesn't have any doubt in his
Quran to go check changed corrupted
scripture is that what he's telling him
to do yeah but the Quran does confirm
the books but he also he he also says
wait wait a second so Allah so Allah is
confirming corrupted scripture changed
corrupted scripture he's saying yeah
those changed corrupted scripture it's
true and you can go check that to make
sure the Quran is right no no he didn't
say like the the Bible is corrupted in
that sense like he says that the verse
that God just revealed in the Quran you
could see that it lines up with the
Bible he's not talking about the whole
Bible and what and what if it doesn't
what if the ver what if in the Quran it
doesn't line up with the Bible what does
that say about the Quran does would
Muhammad have a right to doubt the Quran
if it didn't line up with the Bible
according to this verse yes he would
have the right to doubt the Quran but it
the Bible did confirm the the scriptures
so so I want you to notice the
implications of what you just said it's
very important what you just said okay
you just acknowledged that if the Quran
did not line up with the Bible then what
I'm trying to say but it's what you said
I'm not say the whole Bible is true no
worries if the Quran does not line up
with the Bible then Muhammad would have
a right to doubt the Quran which means
it's not the Quran that's an authority
over the previous scriptures it's the
previous scriptures that's an authority
over the Quran so if the Quran doesn't
align with the Bible with the previous
scriptures the Torah the Psalms the
gospel then the Quran is false and you
have every right to doubt it well well
not like you can't really like say the
whole book well I think Muhammad like
God was talking about God was telling
Muhammad to you know he revealed you a
verse you can go check the previous
scriptures
and that maybe that scripture wasn't
changed like not all of the Bible has
changed yeah so so Allah sending
Muhammad on a on a maybe goose chase huh
but you know go go ahead if you're
doubting the Quran go ahead and check
the previous scriptures maybe they were
changed maybe they were not maybe you'll
find some luck let's say that let's say
let's say Muhammad does that goes to the
previous scriptures and he sees that one
of you know he sees that oh yeah it does
align with the Quran right or the Quran
does align with the with the Bible but
the part that he's reading that lines up
with the Quran has changed how do you
know that that part is not changed
because it confirms with the Quran
that's not how you judge that's not what
the Quran says how to judge well I'm not
familiar with that verse you know I'm
not like a I've been just starting to
get into religion and I understand what
you're trying to say but maybe I'm not
knowledgeable to answer your question
it's not that it's not it's not about
you being knowledgeable Omar it's not
about you being a shake good it's
literally comp literally common sense
you don't have to be a an expert to
understand what what we're saying here
you don't so what I'm challenging you to
do and I'm going let you go with this
okay because you know we've I guess
we've reached our limit what I'm
challenging you to do is to critically
think bro okay I want you to critically
think about what we just went over and
the implications what this actually
means when it's if the Quran doesn't
line up with the Bible
according to this verse that you have
every right to doubt the Quran or if
you're going to go with what you say
that you know or maybe well those
scriptures were changed so then Allah is
sending Muhammad to changed scripture
corrupted changed scripture that can be
changed in one place and correct in
another place but it could be changed
who knows and he's sending him to
corrupted scripture to help his doubts
does that make sense that Allah would
send Muhammad to a corrupted book that
has changes in distortions in it to help
his doubts about the Quran does that
make sense there's probably you know a
meaning to that verse like if you
actually research that I haven't
researched it like I get you're looking
at it from Face Value but all right bro
you all right